thank you dr. Chris
for this wonderful remarks and it
reminds me that all of us are members of
the community as perry was saying it is
the advocacy month and we can all be
advocates for continuing support and
funding and finding treatment for
individuals that are suffering from
mental illness before we really get the
presentations underway I know every year
we have people that attend because they
just heard that maybe a family member
received a diagnosis of borderline
personality disorder or maybe they have
a new patient who has this diagnosis and
they're coming to this conference to
learn different ways that treatment can
be implemented and to learn about this
disorder and so we like to start off
every conference with just a rundown of
what this disorder is at least according
to the GSM the definition of borderline
personality disorder in the dsm-5 is
that it's a pervasive pattern of
relationship or self-image or affective
instability it's my and marked
impulsivity that's indicated by five or
more of the following symptoms as you
can see the symptoms are very diverse
they include efforts to avoid
abandonment unstable and intense
interpersonal relationships identity
disturbance dangerous impulsivity in at
least two areas that are not related to
recurrence suicidal behavior gestures
threats or self-mutilation which is a
separate criteria affective instability
due to this kind of marked reactivity of
mood chronic feelings of emptiness
inappropriate or intense anger or
difficulty controlling that anger and
transient or stress-related paranoia or
severe disassociative symptoms and if
you look at this very heterogeneous mix
of criteria we find that we can kind of
boil it down in some ways to three
general areas of dysfunction unstable
relationships affective dysregulation
and difficulties with impulse control
and as you listen to the presentations
today you'll see that different
presentations are focusing on different
specs of the symptom presentation if we
look at how common BPD is generally I
talk about how common it is in adults at
this conference and as you can see it's
typically 1 to 2 percent in the general
population and clinical studies show
that it's about 10% of outpatients and
about 20% of impatience and adults but
one of the reasons that we felt it was
so important to cover the topic that we
are covering today is because of the
prevalence rates that you see on the
right an adolescence and community
studies although it in some studies it's
around 1% other studies really
recurrently show that it can be as
frequent as 3% in adolescents and
clinical studies show that as high as 22
percent of outpatients and up to 49% so
almost half of all impatience meet
criteria for this disorder this really
speaks to why this conference is so
important in addressing the needs of
children and adolescents with these
potential symptoms you're also going to
hear about a new dsm-5 definition
disruptive mood dysregulation disorder
was a which is a potential adolescent
kind of premorbid characteristic to this
I'm a potential alternative way to
conceptualize and diagnose the related
symptoms so to tell you a little bit
about today's presentations we're gonna
take a developmental arc that starts
from infancy and goes to adolescents in
the morning dr. Slade a member of the
Yale Child Study Center will discuss
minding the baby which is an
intervention for new at-risk mothers to
reduce the risk of attachment problems
and improve health outcomes in their
infants next up will be dr. paraplegic
OVA who is a former postdoctoral fellow
here at Yale who is now an assistant
professor at Weill Cornell in
Westchester she very recently finished a
project in which she has modified DBT
principles and develops new adaptations
that are appropriate for children as
young as seven years old she'll tell us
a little bit about that intervention
today following that we have two
speakers who'll tell us a little bit
about their their lived experiences with
BPD Allison brief fennely will
her personal experiences of living with
this disorder and treatment and Jennifer
brick will give her experiences as a
mother of a child who was part of the
initial treatment study I just mentioned
for DBT for children for disruptive mood
dysregulation disorder in the afternoon
we will we will have stalks from dr.
karla sharp who's going to tell us a
little bit about the science behind an
application of mentalizing interventions
and following her will be dr. miller who
will discuss recent advancements in DBT
for adolescents and after that we'll
have a panel discussion so next up I'm
gonna have dr. Axelrod take over he's
the moderator of the day and we are so
pleased to have seth back with us you
might have remember that he was not with
us last year but we are very grateful
for the fact that he has returned so
please join me in welcoming Seth for the
rest of the moderation
thank you very much Emily I could not be
more delighted to have our conference
our annual conference entering its 11th
year to have all of you with us all of
our speakers all the people that make
this happen I would like to thank dr.
crystal for joining us with opening
remarks and the Costello's Matt and Ann
for speaking about family connections I
want to say a quick thank you to my co
directors to Perry Hoffman representing
national education alliance who is an
extremely humble person who really tries
to avoid the spotlight and I want to say
is really a hero in terms of bringing
education about these problems about the
treatments around nationally
internationally providing congressional
briefings that have led to things like
the the United States House of
Representatives declaring May borderline
personality disorder Awareness Month
also working with Samsa to bring BPD
into focus and it's treatments bringing
it to Nami so that's recognized as a
major mental illness so I really want to
say that that this conference the entire
idea of it is completely based on what
Perry has done with with making this
organization so I want to express thank
you there I want to also express and the
other person who has been speaking so
far in introduce in the conference dr.
Emily Ansel who I was so happy got
involved with the conference's several
years back and kind of helping out
helping make it happen it's a huge
endeavor and then last year really
stepped up in my absence I was having
health issues and she made the
conference happen and is a huge huge
undertaking and the reality is that this
year as well she's made this conference
happen and I'm incredibly thrilled
delighted indebted I certainly have
joined her in doing it but but she
really just deserves a huge recognition
for making today happen so I wanted to
acknowledge her I am going to take a few
to touch base on some logistics related
to continuing education credits and some
requirements we have for just making
sure that everyone's aware of a few
points this this paragraph is in your
packets it describes what the policies
are of making sure that we're being very
open about any potential conflicts of
interest in terms of any of the
presenters including myself in terms of
whether there's any personal gain or
anything like that and so you can read
that this following statement is part of
the process this conference will address
advances in family and individual
treatments and interventions that
support children and adolescents with
borderline personality disorder features
and their family members in order to
receive continuing education units you
must attend the full program day
sponsorship of this conference was
provided by Clear View treatment centers
and silver Hill Hospital in addition we
disclose that our presenters and
planners have the following potential
conflicts of interest that are also
included in your conference program and
these include myself and dr. Alec Miller
who will be with us who have had
contracts royalties related to from
Guilford press who also do training
consultation through behavioral tech and
Francesca who's a doctor Francesca
paraplegic Cova is another of our
presenters who's also recently started
doing some training through behavioral
tech so you'll be hearing about certain
treatments and those treatments are
connected to some of these things where
we potentially undo make personal gain
so to be aware of that and in case that
influences anything
you